AGENDA.
BUT WE BEGIN WITH SID VICIOUS
AND THE CLINTONS, THAT’S THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
SID BLUMENTHAL THE OLDER FIGURED
OF THE CLINTON SCANDALS OF THE
90s IS BACK IN THE NEWS, ALL
SIGNS ARE POINTING TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT HILLARY’S
POLITICAL HIT MAN WITH THAT
PAGE BOY HAIRCUT WAS A LIKELY
SOURCE FOR THE INFAMOUS STEELE
DOSSIER.
>> WHEN YOU HEAR WHERE ONE OF
THE SOURCES IS YOU’RE GOING TO
THINK I’VE HEARD THAT NAME
SOMEWHERE BEFORE.
>> FOREIGN SOURCE?
>> DOMESTIC SOURCE, I’M TRYING
TO THINK OF HOW
SECRETARY CLINTON TO FIND HIM.
>> Laura: RECALL THAT ONCE A
LEFTY JOURNALIST FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND THE
NEW REPUBLIC WORKED ALONGSIDE
HIS OLD PAL PAUL BEGALA IN THE
CLINTON WHITE HOUSE.
HIRED IN 1997, THEY WERE THE TWO
MAN BOMB SQUAD COMMITTED TO
SMEARING AND SLAMMING ANYONE WHO
IS MAKING LIFE DIFFICULT FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND MRS. CLINTON.
HE WAS A PRIME GRAND JURY
WITNESS DURING THE MONICA
LEWINSKY SCANDAL AND IS CREDITED
TO LICKING NASTY STORIES TO THE
PRESS TO DEFILE THE REPUTATION
OF THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR KEN
STARR.
HOLD ONTO THAT THOUGHT.
BLUMENTHAL AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN
AS SID VICIOUS WAS ONE OF
HILLARY’S MOST LOYAL ENABLERS
AND FIERCEST ATTACK DOGS.
AS THE ULTIMATE WASHINGTON
INSIDER, HE GLOMMED ONTO THE
CLINTONS AND HIS ASSOCIATION
WITH THEM BECAME THE MEAL TICKET
THAT NEVER RAN OUT.
THINK OF IT THIS WAY, LIKE A
MAGNET ON A PIECE OF ROTTING
CARRION EXCEPT NASTIER.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PHONY
STEELE DOSSIER, I ALWAYS KNEW
SOMETHING SEEMED ODD THAT THAT
THE CLINTONS HAD MORE TO DO WITH
IT THAN JUST PAYING FOR IT.
ONE OF HER HOLD HENCHMEN MIGHT
EVEN BE BEHIND A SUM OF ITS
LURID DETAILS.
BLUMENTHAL MANAGED TO LAND THE
NIFTY ROLE OF ADVISING HILLARY
WHEN SHE WAS AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND GETTING
$10,000 A MONTH AS A CONSULTANT
FOR THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
WHAT DID HE DO FOR THAT TEN
GRAND A MONTH?
HE PROVIDED SOMETHING CALLED
MESSAGE GUIDANCE.
IN EMAILS REPORTED ON BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," WE LEARNED
THAT LEVENTHAL FUNNELED ADVICE
TO SECRETARY CLINTON ABOUT
THINGS SUCH AS LIBYA.
NOT BECAUSE HE HAD UNIQUE
EXPERIENCE ON A NORTH AFRICAN
AFFAIRS BUT BECAUSE A FRIEND OF
HIS WANTED IT TO DO BUSINESS
THERE.
WHAT A GUY.
FAST-FORWARD TO THE PRESENT DAY.
THE GRASSLEY-GRAHAM CRIMINAL
REFERRAL CONTAINS THIS.
ONE MEMORANDUM BY MR. STEELE
WHICH WAS NOT PUBLISHED BY BUZZ
FEET IT WAS DATED OCTOBER 9TH
2016.
IT STATES THAT HIS COMPANY
RECEIVED THIS REPORT FROM THE
U.S. STATE DEPARTMENT THAT IT
WAS SECOND IN A SERIES AND IT
WAS INFORMATION THAT CAME FROM A
FOREIGN SUB SOURCE WHO WAS IN
TOUCH WITH REDACTED, WHO PASSED
IT TO REDACTED.
IT IS TROUBLING ENOUGH THAT THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN FUNDED
MR. STEELE’S WORK.
BUT THAT THESE ASSOCIATES WERE
CONTEMPORANEOUSLY FEEDING
ALLEGATIONS RAISES ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS ABOUT HIS CREDIBILITY.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
HAVE BEEN LED TO BELIEVE THAT
STEELE’S DOSSIER SOURCES IN THE
INFAMOUS METS WERE RUSSIAN.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN CLINTON BLACK OPS
SPECIALIST LAUNDERING
INFORMATION TO STEELE THROUGH
THE OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT.
WILD.
WHO MIGHT OF THOSE ASSOCIATES B
BE?
LAST MONTH SENATORS GRASSLEY AND
GRAHAM SENT LETTERS OUT TO THE
DNC ASKING THEM TO PRODUCE ANY
COMMUNICATIONS THEY HAD WITH